one of the greatest risks that faces
humanity over the next two and a half
three and a half maybe close to eight
years that is the Donald Trump possible
presidency is the impact of pausing
progress in science and medical
technology and we're already way behind
in many of these areas we haven't made
nearly as much progress as we would like
climate science halted space travel I
guess sort of restarted in a way that's
going to be good for military
contractors by Donald Trump a few days
ago but not good overall alternative
energy I mean just laughable the idea
that we are going to be helped by the
current administration in alternative
energy progress and last week I told you
about that AIDS research team that
bailed on working for the White House
because they said Donald Trump just
doesn't care he just does not care about
this issue
I have even worse news for you the
science division of the White House has
now been left empty as the final
staffers have bailed this is the Office
of Science and Technology Policy it is
now unstacked they had three staffers
left who were sort of holdovers from the
Obama era they are all gone they dealt
with STEM education they dealt with
biotechnology they dealt with crisis
response Kumar Garg who's a former
staffer under Obama in that office he
sent out a tweet where he said by close
of business today the number of staffers
in the White House's OSTP s Science
Division equals zero what's the
explanation for this from the Donald
Trump administration they say oh don't
worry the work is all going to be done
it's going to be done elsewhere because
this was a division that got way too big
under President Obama isn't it a good
thing to take science seriously enough
and technology seriously enough that you
would actually have a proper full staff
which by the way was of nine three of
whom were left after President Obama
left office we have more and more
serious issues on our planet related to
science and technology why wouldn't we
want that to be a robust department well
you have to honestly wonder if they can
see is better for this division because
if you look
some of Donald Trump's pick for cabinet
positions you have scott pruett for the
epa you have repairing for the
Department of Energy
so while progress on this issue may be
stagnant for the mess for years at least
it won't reverse course okay it's Pat
Silver Lining Ford making an appearance
today who is who is bringing up a fair
point which is isn't it better to have
no one in these positions because that
way no one's doing damage because we
can't even reasonably expect progress to
be made that's interesting we're quickly
getting to what might be an inflection
point in American history in progress an
inflection point is a point in a curve
at which a change in the direction of
the curve of the curvature occurs so if
you look at the image that's up on the
screen this is sort of representative of
when if you imagine a plane leaving
Boston's Logan Airport a slightly
different direction when you leave Logan
Airport could lead to that plane ending
up in Oslo Norway or Frankfurt Germany
the idea being that small differences
initially compound over time and small
changes early can leave you in
drastically different places later this
is arguably such a moment for Humanity
in so many ways and we couldn't possibly
have a worse person at the helm at this
time progress in many areas has already
slowed significantly I'm reading Tyler
Cowens book the complacent class we're
going to be interviewing him in a couple
of weeks and he talks about how you know
transportation speeds have basically
been stagnant if anything they've slowed
down because of more car traffic and
airplanes being slowed down to save fuel
major medical developments have slowed
down infrastructure has slowed down
wages are stagnant space travel is
stagnant and while we're arguably on the
cusp of big advancements in those areas
we won't know that until it happens and
lots of people don't get it they like
Trump nationalism go USA we're winning
the truth is that the lack of winning
that society has been seeing for a long
time goes above and beyond Donald Trump
and clearing out the Science and
Technology office at the
Whitehouse could not be a bigger
disaster it's also quite strange too
because a lot of these topics are not
very controversial you science
technology engineering math crisis
aversion all that stuff it's not as
controversial as say climate changes
it's just because they don't care that
that's it that's your spot on which is
why why is this even so controversial
it's like hey we don't really need
people doing things and hiring people to
work at the White House let's just
shrink it doesn't matter if they'd be
doing work that is almost universally
considered to be good work today's
episode made possible by taga dabbe to
hosting specialist taga dev offers a
range of flexible hosting packages
including dedicated VPS and cloud server
options they also do custom server
solutions and colocation services taga
dab has a really user-friendly interface
and excellent customer support team
their expert hosting specialists also
are there friendly support team and they
give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of 9 point 7
out of 10 you know that taga dab takes
their customer service very very
seriously with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is offering you as a david
pakman show viewer or listener a twenty
British Pound free credits about twenty
four US dollars to all new customers
signing up to give you a chance to try
their services to take advantage of it
go to signup tag adapt comm /td PS for
more information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up taga Deb comm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS
20